in the last video i just discussed a
personal balance sheet and what
illiquidity or what insolvency means and
if you understood that i think we're now
ready to tackle what a balance sheet of
some of these potentially troubled banks
might look like and i'm not going to you
know go into the details but i'm going
to give you the big picture and i think
that's that's essentially what what
matters so essentially these banks they
have a bunch of assets and i'll i'm
going to talk about banks very generally
right now both commercial and investment
banks in a future video i'll tell you
the difference between the two and and
what regulation means and what leverage
means and all of that maybe i'll touch
on that in this video but let's just
kind of think about a generic balance
sheet for a bank so it's assets
so assets
so i don't know i'm just going to make
up some things
let's say that it has
i don't know
1 billion
1 billion in
government bonds u.s government bonds
i'm just throwing that in there just as
kind of filler just to show you that
there could be a lot of different types
of assets in there let's say that they
it has another
i don't know
10 billion in
aaa corporate bonds so you know these
are these are loans to
really solvent or or really
high credit were very credit worthy
companies so aaa corporate bonds so
companies that have really good cash
flows
there's very little chance of them
defaulting on their
on their uh
on their loans so and what is a bond
well a bond is just a loan to another
entity right if if if
if you loan me money i could give you an
iou right saying that sal owes you
whatever ten dollars and that iou you
could call that a sal bond so you know
one billion dollars of government bonds
that's an asset that says the government
owes me a billion dollars and in the
meantime it's going to pay me interest
similarly corporate bonds that's saying
that you know these corporations whoever
these bonds are issued by they owe me
collectively 10 billion dollars and in
the meantime they're going to pay me
interest so that's all it is and all an
asset is is something that has some
future economic value and that's what
these are these bonds have some future
economic value they have the value of
the interest payments plus eventually
they're going to pay the 10 billion
dollars back or maybe there's something
less than that so the 10 billion is the
interest payments plus what they're
going to pay you back which might be i
don't know 9.9 billion i'm making up
numbers but that's not the issue here
what's the the crux of the issue is that
there's this stinky acid here actually
let me let me let me let me draw a
couple of more assets here just to show
you that this is the stinkiest of them
all
so let's say i have another uh
another
group of assets i don't know let's say
it's um
let's say it's
let's say i have a
10 billion dollars of commercial
mortgages
commercial mortgages
so this essentially i lent money to um
companies to you know buy land or
develop land or buy buildings that
they're going to go rent out to other
people so once again it's just a loan to
someone else and a loan to someone else
that i've given is an asset because they
owe me interest and eventually they're
gonna have to pay the money back to me
and then finally i'm gonna throw and i'm
not being comprehensive here i'm going
to throw
the the crux of the issue here let's say
that i have
2 well let me see i have 21 right now
let me just make it an even number let's
say that i have 4 billion dollars so it
all adds up to 25. i have four billion
dollars
in residential
cdos
collateralized debt obligations
residential
cdos
and i've done a video on cdos but but
just to kind of have a review see
cdos are a derivative instrument and i
know that sounds complicated but that
just means it derived from another
instrument which probably you know
that's that's a sign that the stink is
starting to emerge from from from this
part of the balance sheet what does it
mean derivative well you take a bunch of
mortgages so i'll just draw it down here
you take a bunch of mortgages so you
know these are house mortgages
maybe you take a million of them you
group them all together
and you end up with a mortgage-backed
security
mortgage-backed security all a
mortgage-backed security is is a loan to
a ton of a big group of people and you
put them all together so that you can
kind of you know be able to to
statistically give it properties because
if you lend to any one person that's
hard to trade but if you lend to a bunch
of people you can it starts to become
something that you could trade with
other people because they can understand
it and you know in aggregate you can say
oh eight percent of the people are going
to default and all of that but anyway
that this isn't the crux of it either i
have a whole video on mortgage-backed
securities
cdo's collateralized debt obligations
are derived from mortgage-backed
securities and that's why they are
called derivative instruments what cdos
are you take these mortgage-backed
securities you know that their loans to
some people in some region of the
country or maybe they're they're
diversified across regions and you slice
and dice them
so
what you do is
you slice them into tranches and i go
into a lot more detail on this in the
other videos
right
and you say
this group of the cdos they'll get the
first payments or if any payments that
go immediately go to this very senior
tranche right and then the next payments
go to this one and then this top tranche
you could call the most junior tranche
it's sometimes called the equity tranche
this
tranche
they're going to get whatever's left
over so if everyone pays they get made
whole but if a lot of people default all
the defaults are gonna hit this tranche
right and to kind of make up the fact
that this is the riskiest tranche or
essentially these people are taking on
all of the risk
and essentially these tranches are
giving all the risk to this tranche
and a tranche is just a layer it's just
a slice okay i don't want to use two
fancy words but in return for taking on
all of the risk this person is going to
get a higher yield so you know while
this person might be getting six percent
this person might be getting seven
percent on their money maybe this person
gets 12 percent on their money and this
is another interesting thing because
this person is the most secure the
ratings agency which i'll probably do a
whole another series of videos on they
might give it like i don't know a triple
a rating and maybe they give this
tranche i'm making up things but maybe
they give it a double a rating but this
equity tranche will get a junkie rating
and because it's a junkie rating no one
is going to want to buy it so the person
who constructed this whole
collateralized debt obligation and who
sold these tranches to the to the public
markets and this process by the way is
called securitization because you're
creating securities out of these assets
that you sell to everyone maybe the
chinese or whoever sovereign wealth
funds
but people only want to buy these
tranches
so the banks have to figure out what to
do with this tranche which is the stinky
equity tranche so most of them just kept
it on their balance sheet they said oh
looks like housing never goes down we
get a really high yield on this so we
are going to keep this tranche for
ourselves and that's what these
residential cdos are that are that are
the crux of the issue but anyway that
was just an aside and so i i wanted to
show you this because these aren't just
any residential cdos these aren't the
triple a's these
they might be some of them but just for
the sake of our argument let's say that
these are junky ones
or smelly
smelly so anyway that's my example bank
asset the asset side of its balance
sheet let's let's think about its
liabilities
so liabilities
let's just say it has a bunch of loans
right so let's say it has
loan a
loan a for i don't know 10 billion
dollars
let me let me actually throw some cash
in here let's say it has a billion
dollars of cash a bank always has to
keep some cash just in case someone asks
for their money right immediately
that's in the context of a commercial
bank but anyway let's say it has some
cash just for immediate liquidity needs
so and the liability side has loan a it
owns someone it owes someone 10 billion
dollars it has
loan b
i don't know let's say it's another 10
billion dollars
and let's say it has loan c
loan c is just to make it interesting
loan c is let's say it's for
three billion dollars
so in this example right now if we
assume that all of these asset values
are correct and all of these liability
values are correct what are this bank's
equity and in this case it's a publicly
traded company what is its shareholders
equity
let's figure it out
it's equity
well its assets are one plus let's see
25 26 billion in assets
right and its liabilities are 23 billion
so 26 billion of assets minus 23 billion
of liabilities means that we have 3
billion
of equity of shareholders equity and
just to make it clear what this equity
is let's say this is a publicly traded
company if you own a share of the
company you own a share of this equity
so let's actually let's just write it
out let's say that this company has
um you know let's call this
um
i don't know yakovia bank
no well i i shouldn't that's too close
let's call this bank a right and let's
say that bank a
bank a
has i don't know let me make up
something let's say that it has
a
i don't know a billion let's say it has
500 million shares
right if you want to yahoo finance you
said how many shares are outstanding it
has 500 million shares
so each share price or the book value of
each share price essentially should be
this three billion dollars of equity
based on the balance sheet and that's
why they call it book equity because the
balance sheet it's often called the
company's books so this is three billion
dollars of equity divided by
the number of shares so each share
should be worth let's see three billion
divided by 500 million it should be six
dollars
of book equity
book
equity
per share
and that's something important to
realize because a lot of people think
that you know if a stock price goes to
zero that you know that means that
you're getting the company for nothing
no that's not true that just means that
the equity is worth zero and i just
realized that i'm out of time i'm going
to continue this in the next video and
and we'll explore this a little bit more
see you soon